am pool scharrte is undoubtedly one
of the most important thinkers of the twentieth
century his existence philosophy
influences not only the
academic discussion but the
entire western civilization
especially the youth in france
, for example, after the second world war
until the 60s there was
its own youth culture students
artists  intellectuals wore
black clothes and
horn-rimmed glasses like they wore as a sign of their existentialist attitude and
the motto of the existentialists was
don't let anyone tell you how you have to
live live honestly and intensely,
both in terms of his love
relationships and friendships and
his political commitment katri was
So the first great philosopher of
freedom
no other emphasized human
freedom of will as much as satire and
because man is free he must
make something of his life and live
as he sees fit
n  if necessary also against all
social rules
he himself, for example, was committed
the war opponent fought for a
more just society wrote hundreds of
petitions and also
had a so
-called open relationship with his partner simon lippe was at that time
still a scandal
in his main work being and
nothing fathomed  sa also appears as
one of the first philosophers the essence
of love
how does love really work what
differentiates it from sexuality what
does it mean to lead a free and
self-determined life how
free we really are
i tried his most important theses in the book for a whopping 60
10 minutes
understandably based on over 50 selected
quotes from saddle and in the
center of this presentation is of
course the structure of the
interpersonal relationship and his
suggestions for free will and you
will see his thoughts can be
directly helpful for your personal life
in ans  bring blow